good morning John special day special
extra video yesterday you talked in your
video about 8/8/08 and terminus the
Harry Potter convention that we went to
i wanted to add that conversation
cause it was just a big deal just
before that event I picked up from
kinkos some very nice people made for me
a hundred cds with my music on it the
album was called songs from Hank Green's
pants terminus edition and I don't
remember anything about it except that I
ripped most of the songs directly from
my own YouTube videos so wasn't like a
really high quality enterprise or
anything we did sell every single one of
the ones that we didn't give away i
wonder if anybody still has a copy of
that or the one that I did before that
the the several songs from Hank Green's
pants which we sold at an event in
Michigan if anybody has either of those
i would like to buy them from you
because it made me realize in a new way
how much support we had from this
Community and it felt so good to be
selling my music and I also kind of want
a memento to remember that day with
because it was a really big day it was
my first Harry Potter convention one of
the first times I played music in front
of people i met a bunch of people that
have still great friends within that I
love dearly to this day and that feeling
of support I got from people buying my
stuff and also you know knowing that it
was going to help me pay bills and stuff
led directly to me creating with Alan Lefstuka
at dftba records you don't
always know when you're inside of a
super life-changing moment and sometimes
you do like for example right now I know
that I'm inside one of those moments
because we're going to have a baby and
that's definitely I've heard pretty
life-changing. But what's very clear to me now
as a person who is adding to his family
and who has a lot of really wonderful
people in his life
who I love a lot is that the things that
make life special aren't necessarily
these big great events and I've gotten
to have a lot of those and am very grateful
for them
very unusual things happen to me so much
even that it starts to seem normal
what makes life special is the people you love
the people who love you and knowing that
and feeling that and helping them feel
it from you. 'Cause I think all too often we
forget about that fabric that holds it
all together
just that we appreciate each other for
who we are. Today is Esther Day,
august 3rd it's a day on which we
celebrate the kind of love that society
is maybe a little less good at celebrating
because they're maybe not quite as
exciting despite the fact that it's the
fabric that holds our entire society
together I love you Jonn I love you
not just because we've been able to do a
lot of really cool weird things together
through this project and not even
because you're a great collaborator and
partner and thinker because you're a
great brother
because you're there for me even when
I'm being a jerk or when I'm confused
and angry and like not even acting in my
own best interest you want the best
things for me you're willing to work
through my issues to help me when I need
help which is all the time and I want so
much and try so hard to be the same
thing for you because I love you not for
any other reason just that one
life changing moments
they're great whether you know you're in
them or not
I think they deserve to be looked at and
enjoyed it's sort of like you know
connected with and realize that you're
on a trajectory in your life and you're
moving through it and having things
happen to you that's all, that's all
wonderful but achievements aren't what
life is made of I think the best lives
are made of love and I want to thank
Esther for giving us a day to remember
that. John you'll see me tomorrow for a
very cool thing that I'm excited about
that we've already gone for a long time
so get ready for that
at mostly if you're American though
sorry everybody else you get an extra
video this week if you're not American
get this one
so sorry everyone who is not American